you guys for being here today I'm going
to talk about energy efficiency for your
data science ecosystem but why is this
topic important at all if you look at
the chart on the right side you see that
in every minute in 2019 there is a lot
happening so for example there is 2.1
millions snaps created we cannot even
catch up looking at this content as a
personal as a person right or for
example on YouTube there is 4.5 million
videos viewed if you have two kids you
probably know this video baby shark and
this is a very short video it's just
like song for kids it's like around 2
minutes and it's been viewed 4 billion
times it's yeah we also did this morning
yeah so it 4 billion views of this very
short video it's a lot of energy
consumption it can even power up like if
I want to translate this for something
more tangible it's enough to power 155
households for a year and when I say
households I mean like all the
appliances everything included it's a
lot of energy consumption if you want to
have all these services up and running
24/7 and we need to consume a lot of
power yeah and if you look at the
forecast for energy for the IT sector
you can see that it's even increasing
more like the demand is more and we also
doing more computation we are automating
more services so we're even like going
to the direction of like even consuming
more and if you take for example 2019 as
an example it's around 2.5
terawatt-hours a year and to make it
more translatable to what we can compare
actually it's more than energy
consumption of India and Russia in the
year so if IT sector was a country it
would be like in the
list of four top four countries that
consume energy
this is serious issue and also I think
at the data science community we can
have big impact in the organization's we
work we can actually make insightful
decisions about this okay so some
technology here but what do we talk
about when we talk about efficiency
efficiency is output divided by input
you want to maximize the output by a
given input right and you can apply this
formula to many domains many scopes like
for example take this picture as an
example you have one hundred fifteen
hundred watts of sunlight and then you
get for example 450 watts of power so
efficiency is around thirty percent okay
we can apply this for energy efficiency
and look at it from the tasks
perspective so given a number of tasks
you consume a number of and an amount of
energy so what you want to maximize is
to like for example maximize the number
of tasks or minimize an amount of energy
right and we also have power consumption
which relates to the rate of the energy
consumption over time to measure power
consumption and energy consumption there
is many kinds of formula in the
literature but most of them actually
come to this form formula that they
divide per component so you take each
component in the system and then you
measure the static power and then the
dynamic power and then you multiply that
with the weight and then you have the
power of Toto the why do we actually
separate the static and dynamic is
because usually when you turn on
electronic devices you already start
consuming because you you are in the
standby mode and and then as soon as you
try to have utilization rate then you
have some dynamic power added up to the
static power and then the power of total
power we are multiplied by the duration
of the execution you have the
total energy consumption so how can we
actually measure energy efficiency in
data science to do that we need to
answer a number of questions from
different perspectives so for example
what are we measuring what kind of tasks
are we talking about is it about data
cleaning tasks are we talking about for
example monitoring tasks about for
example model training what are we
focusing on this is very important
because then you're also talking about
the components that you want to measure
right and what kind of resources are
involved in this setup are they like
cloud-based resources or are they our
promise or do we want to talk about for
example computation intensive tests and
then therefore computation computational
resources are involved or about network
what are what is the focus and also from
which users perspective are we talking
about from in-depth for example AWS
providers perspective of all from run
start then this completely changes the
story how can how we can approach the
problem actually but all this a story
that I said it's a at the end comes to
having systems being self adaptive so
when we have our system self adapt if
they can adapt to new changes at runtime
and make new actions based on the energy
consumption and the changes in the
patterns and stuff right so to make your
system self adaptive you need to realize
make functionalities it's very easy four
steps first you start by monitoring the
resources you analyze all the new
information get you oh and then you
detect some changes you say it takes up
abnormalities and based on that you plan
the next execution step that you should
have and then you execute again you
monitor to see what was the impact of
the all the changes you make to the
system but then how can you employ that
make functionalities in in the data
science lifecycle this is the life cycle
we have a Tron start probably you have
similar
in your organization so first you start
for example with business understanding
what is the problem we're going to solve
as from the data science perspective and
then you try to understand the data what
kind of data sources I can use and then
you start doing some pork
experimentation okay but kind of model
can I use for this which hyper parameter
tuning is what is going to work best for
this how can i scale this solution up
and this sort of questions for the pork
experimentation and then you start okay
if it's a decision to go towards solving
that problem then you go to the phase of
planning the project and then you
implement it and then you maintain it's
right the tips that I'm covering today
is going to help you with these three
steps so for the pork and the
implementation and maintaining the
solution and usually like you want to
actually think more for the last two
phases because these are the steps that
going to last in your organization and
if you think more and then you are more
insightful about the decisions you make
in the last two phases you're gonna
benefit more than in the long-run okay
so tip number one I already mentioned it
a couple of times is that you need to
monitor your resources who in this crowd
actually money towards resources for
energy efficiency purposes oh you do
okay that's that's oh that's nice I
didn't expect actually to see any hands
that's that's good news for me but
usually companies have thresholds for
like higher utilization of resources
like you usually get alarms okay 80% of
CPU is utilized Ram is going to be used
that way and we are alarmed by that but
usually we're not actually alarmed with
low utilization rates and we don't care
about that right so we're like okay I
think the Pokes poke experimentation
phase we're like okay give me the
biggest instance you can give me that I
try this model and I see that it works
but it's really important to get
insights from the patterns and it also
gives a lot of insights about
the domain like for example you might
have a scenario that your systems are
not used during the weekends or after
working hours so you could actually tune
based on that and save a lot of energy
with that so one approach would be that
you could one approach could be that you
could actually rely and the cloud
provider itself these days they also
they have a lot of data about how we use
our resources and they actually provide
insightful reports so for example this
is from AWS cost management and you see
that they they can offer like
utilization rates on monthly basis cost
and also use it hours this simple graph
shows like for example on different
months what was the cost on different
services and in home in how many hours
they were actually used so this we can
actually use to see ok how much we're
using the services and with which
utilization rate and we can benefit from
this even like from AWS for example I
think other cloud providers have similar
services you can even get purchase
recommendations it's really interesting
like they say like ok so you have used
these three instances last month and you
cost this month this amount so maybe you
want to replace those three with this
another instance and you save up this
amount so these are interesting insights
that you can get from the providers and
actually embed into your own system they
also provide api's and you can actually
use it from your own systems another
approach would be that you take control
yourself so you say ok I want to have
this after scaling use auto scaling
groups as we do in run start and so with
outer scaling you define a range you say
ok I need this minimum number of
instances maximum number of instances
and based on the utilization rate it
it's kind of fluctuate based on that and
then the number of instances goes up and
down right you all you can go even like
more complex with that and then
you can define two different schemes
like a scale-up scheme and a scaled-down
scheme and then you plan use cron jobs
to actually plan it accordingly like for
example we are we are using after
scanning crews for one for serving one
of our api's and we want to make sure
that we have two instances running at
working hours and in the other hours we
just want to have one instance there and
based on the patterns we know that okay
that's going to be enough therefore as
you can see here like we we change from
one node to two nodes over time like two
times a day because no one time day and
then we also defined a cron job like at
what time it should start and then if
you look at the utilization right it's
kind of looking very stable you also can
use Python libraries to include the
monitoring information to your program
like for example this PSU till you can't
get the CPU percentage at a given time
and also like all information but you
know like memory like okay what is the
available memory and what's a percentage
stuff like that okay tip number two
choose your ml bundles wisely so you can
actually adopt to use resource efficient
models you can be insightful about that
as well and you can so there is a lot of
models like there is a lot of libraries
that you can use it fresh off the shelf
but they are not customized to your
specific problem right so you can if you
try to investigate more ok how can I
actually use the hyper parameters based
on the previous talks even in this
conference there were suggestions that
you should actually understand each
hyper parameter better and then you can
actually tune better based on your
problem and it's gonna save also in
terms of resources that you are using
like for example there are also some
models that are provided for the purpose
of being more energy efficient and for
also resource efficient which at the end
translates to more energy efficiency
like for example this algorithm neural
Nets that are introduced by Google
efficient net so they use less number of
flops for higher accuracy and you could
for example when choosing different
algorithms you could like for example
taxi like that also as well so the whole
idea is that you bring energy
consumption into equations like there is
this research comparing NLP algorithms
Elmer and Bert and then if you look at
the results you see that ok where it is
much more energy consuming and also like
in different set of hardware and it's
also consuming a lot of money in terms
of like cloud computing costs I'm not
saying that don't use Bert and that's
not the message that's the message I'm
getting is that just being insightful
about this it might be the case that all
only Bert can solve your problem
but you need to be insulted about that
and make that decision to be insightful
so one way would be to also use energy
related metrics so for example when you
when you're using ml flow and you want
to like for example log different kind
of metrics about the model itself you
can also take into account the training
time or like for example what kind of
resources we are using here or for
example what is the CPU percentage which
I just showed like with PS util you
could also take it at a given time so
this this will also change the way you
look at the problem it's not only about
the model but the whole picture like ok
because at the time your production I
think this model you're gonna use
resources over and over again so it's
it's really good that you know ok this
is gonna be the impact of my algorithm
in the long run another important factor
about machine learning algorithms is
that we need to retrain them but we need
to also answer this question like how
often is too often and like what is my
strategy to actually make the retraining
schedule do I do it based on just some
fixed schedule I say okay once a week I
want to risk retrain this model or I
have another mechanism like for example
I base my decisions based on some
performance degradation these are some
kind of discussions that you should ask
based on the data you have like for
example if my data set is not changing
at all like in terms of distribution
maybe also there is no need to do it too
often to retrain every week so we should
be more careful about like how often we
want to retrain because retraining is
not only about the model but you also do
a lot of pre-processing to make the data
ready to for the bottle right so all
these steps are energy consuming if not
for the good purpose
so last tip is about optimization of
your code so it's really important that
you use efficient data structures the
efficient libraries and also coding
styles you also should go for
computationally efficient algorithms
it's it's sometimes the code might look
ugly but at the end you you will have a
better serving code for the environment
I'm not saying that the code should not
be able like don't care about the code
that it's not communicative to other
people and it's not readable at all no
and that's not the message but what I'm
saying is that make the trade-off all
the time think about another aspect of
the code that you can take into account
like for example okay I want to copy
this data frame yes I need to do that
because I don't want to I want to make a
functional code but then how many times
do I copy that this is the question that
trade-off you can make right and it's
also interesting to know that faster is
not always better like it take the core
example like if you go with the fastest
speed or with the lowest speed in both
cases you're not the most energy
efficient so there is the sweet spot for
everything though so there is also a
sweet spot for performance
four-speed in your code that you can
fine-tune like see okay how I actually
can actually like make this trade-off
and make it more efficient and also in
terms of like performance and also
energy for data structures looking at
the Big O and the complexity of the data
structures and the operations would help
a lot in finding the right way and also
you need to be careful about the
operations you do on different data
structures for example this research is
comparing different collections in Java
and it's just like different operations
three different kind of operations like
for example insertion one item in the
beginning or in the middle of the
collection or at the end right and you
see that some of the collections that do
good in one type are doing really bad in
another type so the message is that you
need to be careful like what kind of
operations you want to do and then based
on that choose the right data structure
okay so takeaway messages is that we
have three tips that is gonna improve a
lot in your data science ecosystem and
some of them actually can actually be
applied in any software engineering case
right first first first is that monitor
your resources because at the end okay
we have the software can be efficient or
inefficient but at the end the hardware
is actually consuming the jewels so it's
really important to be aware like what
kind of resources you're using and be
aware of like underutilized resources
and try to minimize that second option
is to choose your models wisely and be
mindful about the decisions you make and
don't use algorithms just fresh off the
shelf try to understand like what kind
of parameters you can feel better to
make it more efficient and lastly
optimize your code for the purpose of
resource efficiency
okay that was my talk and we are hiring
if you have any questions I'm here to
answer
[Applause]